one of the men that panders to us on a
regular basis is Destiny now I I've met
Destiny he's a nice guy you know um
talks a lot of he said I was um I
saw a clip of him saying I was just my
career was over
yeah it's just been going terrible 50
million views of my awful terrible
terrible you know just you know we're
not expanding we're not it's just yeah
horrible horrible anyways so me falling
off nobody will watch this anyway
um let's pull up the destiny clip the
the world's number one panderer destiny
clears podcast host education and
working first they missed that
opportunity to have a child when they're
at their Prime fertility years she can
Rectify that wrong because she got the
kids out to win she can pursue that
career after the fact but if she does
the other way around she might end her
immunity to have children in the future
not to knock any old people but like
re-entering the workforce when you're 40
years old that's a tall order that's
really difficult but at least it's
possible you can have a kid at 40 that's
possible too yeah it's probably easier
to have a kid at 40 than it is to go
into the workforce after being out of a
virtual yeah actually yeah absolutely it
is of course you can't have kids I mean
let's be honest dude
it's higher risk
as opposed to a woman at 40 being like
here I am now I'm gonna go get a job I
would argue that a woman has a higher
chance of Landing a job at 40
re-entering the workplace and getting an
education thanks affirmative action
maybe she goes into a job field that's
nominated by men versus being 40 years
old and trying to bring a child to full
term sure you would just be completely
wrong do you think it's like a 70 chance
of like a miscarriage woman is pregnant
at 40. it's significantly higher bro
like 90 at that point men like this men
like this simp and Pander to women
he's telling me it's going to be harder
to get a job
it's harder to get a job at 40 than it
is to have a kid so I just Googled this
fertility specialist quote approximately
a five percent chance of getting
pregnant per menstrual cycle I mean I
wasn't even in social media until three
years ago two years ago
look what I built in two three years you
can't get back your fertility but you
certainly
can get skills and provide value to add
to the workforce you know what's funny I
found out a stat the other day if you
hit 30 and you're still single as a
woman
you have less than a 50 chance of having
a kid so you're more likely to not have
a kid than have one because one it takes
time to find a guy that's going to marry
you you know or like want to have a kid
with you and two
um yeah and these are just numbers so
do I think it's harder to get a job as a
woman
and can we stop acting like this is the
other thing like he's acting like women
have all these like high-powered careers
like I think the number one
job for women is caretaking
which you can do with a family
and it's like they just want and then
the the same guys will shame women like
me for calling this out when it's like
you want me to just like watch you guys
lie to women
and say nothing like you want to just
let all the feminists and the leftists
just talk talk talk and and not call
this out
you really you think it's harder like
like let's just let's just use common
sense the average age for menopause is
51.
so at 40 you're 10 years away from
menopause and let me get this straight
you have a better it's harder for you to
get a job caretaking
than it is to have a kid and what he
doesn't realize is okay he gets to make
money off of this but it's actually
like detrimental to women that listen to
him it's harder to get to get a job than
have a kid at 40. okay
okay when you have a five percent chance
of conceiving every menstrual cycle
and that's I just can't stand liars like
and that's the thing Destiny and you see
it because it's so weird debating him
because he just like looks at his phone
the whole debate like the whole debate
he's just like on his phone like he's
not trying to he's trying to win the
debate he's not trying to find what's
true like and it's just like you can't
actually believe that a five percent all
right 40 year old women are just popping
out babies left and right you see that
often I see plenty of 40 year old women
with jobs
and I really the funny thing is he
really went into an industry and
dominated in it in the first few years
like he's been on the internet forever
like why is he acting like coming into
an industry
is impossible just because you're old
whatever whatever it's like he'll he'll
pray he'll he'll any feminist lie he'll
like sell the miracle of like yes you
can you can have a kid at 40. but when
it comes to stuff that he's done and
achieved it's like they they never push
like you can do it you can make money
you can go into an industry and dominate
you can change careers but it's like
weird when it when it serves the
feminist imperative it's like they'll
push it like it's likely improbable but
they're the first ones to say it's
unlikely and improbable to like come in
and dominate in the field
okay but yeah I mean maybe I'm wrong I'm
just a big liar a big you know my career
is just over and ended and I just have
the worst luck
just you know I'm just a big liar and I
just hate women I'm a big woman hater